attention your voice can be stolen the
first instance of voice theft happened
in 2019 cyber criminals used the voice
of the company's CEO to convince his
colleague to make a transfer of 243
000 it's not hard to get a sample of
your voice a scammer can ring you and
record the conversation and then feed
this copy of your voice into a neural
network and create audio of any content
how could scammers use your voice they
can crack voice access codes to steal
some valuable information most commonly
your voice can be used to defraud money
from people fraudsters could create an
edited audio recording to Blackmail you
don't try to negotiate with a
blackmailer contact the police and warn
your friends that you have fallen victim
to a scammer scammers could manipulate
you by pretending to be a member of your
close friends or family and in this
situation you should either hang up and
phone the real number of your
acquaintance or you should ask questions
that only this person would know the
answer to alongside a spoofed number
this scam can be very hard to spot leave
a like if you want to know more about
number spoofing in our next video